just like that we've wrapped up most of
the year it would be trying to say that
time flies but it does feel that way and
it still hasn't sunk in that by the time
this video comes up we'll be getting
ready to say goodbye once more to some
of our favorite series but as it's
always been there's always something
good on the horizon to look forward to
2024 is weeks away and we already have
what's looking like a pretty great
season to open up the year here's what I
think are the top 10 most anticipated
anime for winter 20 24 so let's dive
in original anime metallic Rogue is set
to
[Music]
debut Studio bones is set to celebrate
its 25th anniversary next year so what
better way to commemorate such a
momentous occasion for the studio
responsible for bringing us a lot of our
favorites then with a new original anime
metallic Rogue as of the time of writing
is still an anime shrouded in mystery
however the anticipations there with it
being a really cool take on the Sci-Fi
genre integrating what seems to be
magical girl elements into a Sci-Fi
setting that reminds people of Axel
world or tiger and Bunny if you've been
around long enough to know those two
shows with more sfog gear looming in the
Horizon looks like the magical girl
sci-fi subgenre is pushing for a
comeback have you checked the trailer
for metallic Rogue yet it's pretty cool
and I do like the atmosphere evokes with
a unique musical accompaniment with a
pretty neat setting and some popular
voice actors leading the charge Studio
bones looks to open 20 24 with a
[Music]
bang a sign of affection is also due
this
[Music]
January now if you prefer something a
little bit more down to earth and sweet
a sign of affection is shaping up to be
this Winter's Comfort anime it tells a
story of a hearing impaired protagonist
and how her otherwise lonely world
brightens upon meeting the one person
who accepts her and understands her it's
a really touching romance manga that's
been deserving of an adaptation for so
long and I'm glad that we're finally
going to see it as someone who's read
some of the source material I'd say that
it's super easy to get invested on some
of the characters and root for them a
sign of affection is a light-hearted
romance that ought to touch the hearts
of anyone planning to watch it we'll
need that temporary pree from the
harshness of the world and this upcoming
anime ought to give us some hope and
comfort when we need it the
most blue excist is making its return in
2024 blue ex assist in
2024 yeah your eyes aren't deceiving you
blue exist as an anime adaptation has
had its share of ups and downs but it's
undeniable that it's garnered quite the
size I able fan base over the years with
the last anime project being in 2017 the
announcement just this year was quite a
pleasant surprise especially for those
who've given up hope on a new anime the
best part of it all it's set to adapt
the Illuminati Arc which is according to
a lot of people one of the best arcs the
entire Series has to date whether the
anime will do this Arc Justice is up in
the air but you can't blame the fans for
being very excited is this the season
that will go far on above giving Blue
Exorcist fans a return to Glory much
like what Thousand-Year blood War did
for Bleach keeping my fingers
crossed next up is sangoku
[Music]
Yoko SLE yo Yoko from the guy behind
Lucifer and the biscuit Hammer has a
premise that while shows quite a lot of
Promise does feel pretty plain you have
the fantasy world divided into humans
and monsters a monster protagonist who
fights for humans and a human brother
who hates his own kind they along with
an aspiring swordsman go on a journey
where they cross paths with both
factions uncovering conspiracies and
Mysteries in the greater World in their
travels however if there's an upand
cominging anime that showcases the
importance of context shows the magic of
payoffs of viewing the story as a bigger
picture it's got to be soku Yoko getting
three cores quite an irregularity Works
in its disregard as it's a title that
makes a lot more sense once you get to
the second half of it from what I can
see it's something that both newcomers
and Anime veterans can enjoy especially
those who are into fantasy and action
with biscuit hamers anime ending up the
way it is is it time for mizukami to get
a Redemptive adaptations through his
other work huh I sure hope
so
[Music]
chained Soldier is also coming this
winter right after sangoku Yoko we have
another upcoming title from another
renowned author this time it's the aami
kill Creator's time to shine with his
new title that feels eerily similar to
the previous series but with the degree
of fan service pushed into overdrive
chained Sal tells of a Japan ravaged by
entrances to the otherworldly Dimension
M standing in the way of monsters from
said Dimension are members of the all
female anti-demon corpse it's an
encounter with a commander from said
group that kickstarts on protagonist
Yuki's story after being saved by kyoka
who recognizes his potential he agrees
to join the anti-demon corpse as her
slave truly not the most flattering of
positions is it but what if Yuki
actually enjoys it fan service Galore
high octane action Haram elements and a
fantasy setting it sounds like a call
back to those 2010s titles like High
School DxD however things have changed
and change Soldier goes even deeper into
the degenerative elements all while
providing us a plethora of amazing
fights I mean that unironically as the
action sequences can be really engaging
and full of strategy something to look
out for at the start of the
year for now hit that like button if
you're enjoying this content let's hurry
and get to the second half of the list
we take a look at the second season of
sukimi I've always been pretty high on
sukimi season one had me in stitches
blly a parody of isaki as a genre you
immediately know what they are and come
in with appropriate expectations of what
you're going to be seeing it still
doesn't make it any less funny when the
execution just hits the right spot for
suuki Mei that largely has to do with
the super fun Ensemble of characters
we're introduced to there's never a dull
moment with marcoo and the rest of the
party in toe they sure kept us waiting
with the new season however announced as
far back as 2021 we really had to wait
over 2 years to see the continuation of
this fun adventure I think that as long
as the anime team remains consistent
with what made season 1 work this second
season should be great I've always
compared this title to gonos subba so I
think it's interesting to note that
we'll be getting Suki miji season 2 with
gonos subba season 3 right around the
[Music]
corner
delicious in Dungeon is up
[Music]
next what is it this isn't my first
encounter with delicious in Dungeon and
it's not much of a surprise to see this
get an adaptation it was a rather
popular manga a couple of years back and
it's not hard to see why it's a title
that disguises itself as a typical sword
and sorcery manga before incorporating
the light tighted parody elements aimed
at the concept of Monster eating the
Monster eating to get stronger concept
is something we've seen in a lot of
isekai and fantasy stories but delicious
IND dungeon takes it up a notch using it
as a backdrop for very compelling
adventures inside the dungeon leading to
it making quite a name for itself back
in the day there's comedy engaging
interactions and most importantly really
creative monster dishes at every turn
it's got a little of everything from
light-hearted moments to sincere
wholesome moments of character growth
don't let the plain promotional art or
the simple synopsis get to you delicious
in Dungeon is a far better series than
any promo material can make it out to be
and it's something you have to read or
watch to truly experience it in
full had enough of mashall well here's
the second season on its
way
[Music]
this was one quick sequel announcement I
think it's more appropriate to call this
mashall season 1 part two it's obviously
a second core disguised as a second
season but you know semantics aside and
more importantly what that means is that
we'll be getting another 12 episodes of
this enjoyable parody I'm not going to
lie mashel on paper isn't anything too
special the thing looks like a parody of
media franchises like one punch Man
Black Clover and Harry Potter but
everything put together just works it's
ENT entertaining the characters are a
quirky and Fun Bunch and the plot while
simple has some Shining Moments of drama
with a handful of stakes if you enjoyed
Mash's first season then you're
definitely going to want to check this
one out if you haven't seen it yet and
are looking for some meta humor and some
over-the-top fights to keep yourself
entertained you might want to take a
shot at
[Music]
mashall class room of elad continues its
role with the third
season delays won't stop the inevitable
and winter 2024 is where we'll finally
get to see the conclusion of classroom
of the Elite's firste set of light
novels we've come a pretty long way from
people wishing for a sequel after season
1 to hitting a major milestone in the
anime adaptation and if the light novels
are any indication we'll be seeing a lot
of even more intense character drama and
M battles for the third season expulsion
is right around the corner and it comes
with high tension and the most climactic
battle Ayan Koji has to face all I'm
going to say is that fans of honami will
also have a lot to look forward to for
this third season now the question
remains if we'll be getting a fourth
season and an anime adaptation of year 2
for now though let's enjoy the ride as
it hopefully finishes
strong to end this this list then we
have solo
leveling It Seems Like Only Yesterday
When anime communities got hyped to High
Heavens with the announcement that solo
leveling is finally getting an anime now
at the tail end of 20123 not only do we
have an anime on its way we're getting a
liveaction project everything's riding
the wave of solo leveling hype and it's
Prime to take the World by storm when
the calendar rolls around to 2024 people
have long been enthralled by the dark
action tale of the weakest Hunter who
Rises up the ranks and goes from weakest
to strongest fighting monsters and
becoming stronger is a tried and tested
formula for an Underdog Story and it
really works mostly due to being
captivated by the struggle and the
eventual Triumph as well as a lot of
cool badass moments integrated with a
simple yet engrossing plot but will solo
leveling live up to the hype generated
by Source material readers or will it
fall into the same fate as those webtune
adaptations of 2020 only time will tell
and the world is
watching which anime are you looking
forward to the most do tell me in the
comments section down below but if
you're interested in living in the
moment and taking a look at some of my
takes for the current season head over
to the channel and check my roster of
top 10 list videos that's it for today
however don't forget to like And
subscribe and I hope I can see you in
the next video thanks for watching